la presencia del partido de ultraderecha
vox en el gobierno de Castilla y león la
comunidad Autónoma más extensa de España
que está situada al norte y oeste de
Madrid sigue creando polémica esta vez
por las declaraciones hechas el jueves
por el vicepresidente regional
integrante de vox en las que anunciaba
izito textualmente su agenda a favor de
la vida y las familias cuatro medidas
que según él ayudarán a frenar los
abortos en la región se obligaría a los
médicos a ofrecer una cuarta ecografía
durante el primer trimestre entre la
semana 6 y 9 de gestación para escuchar
el latido del feto así como asistencias
psicológica a las mujeres que vayan a
abortar además una ecografía 4 de antes
de llevar a cabo la interrupción de el
embarazo Eso sí la obligatoriedad recae
solo sobre el médico pero no sobre la
mujer es decir se puede rechazar las
reacciones nos han hecho esperar y el
gobierno central califica de peligro
para la democracia la coalición hecha
entre el derechista partido popular y
vox Pese a que a nivel nacional el PP el
partido popular se ha des de este
anuncio la presidenta de Madrid Isabel
diez Ayuso que es del mismo partido ha
anunciado una línea telefónica para las
embarazadas un servicio que de hecho ya
existe desde 2019 cabe Resaltar que este
año hay elecciones generales en España y
de ganar el partido popular necesitaría
los escaños de vox para formar gobierno
este partido de ultraderecha califica el
aborto como un atentado contra la vida
pero la ley española protege este
derecho para cualquier mujer Que decida
interrumpir de manera voluntaria un
embarazo de manera Libre hasta la semana
14 de gestación